we we certainly want to be as
comprehensive as possible so we hope
that that all publishers continue to
index and allow us to index their
information but I think there are just
there are so many different sources that
are out there depending on what it is I
think they're just so many different
ways to get out that information again
unique information that that's not
available within Google that that's not
good for us I would also argue because
of the value that we deliver publishers
is probably not a great outcome for them
too so I think it's it's I think we it
really is a symbiotic relationship that
there's there's there's value for us and
being able to have that information on
our side and there's value for them and
in helping us in having us direct people
over over to their to their sites
no I mean look these these relationships
that we have with publishers that really
scan it spans just a sort of a wide
areas of interactions with Google we
work with publishers certainly there's
the new set of things and and the
traffic and the distribution of the
content but we have strong partnerships
with with these publishers whether it's
in the advertising part of our business
or YouTube and content partnerships or
technology or any number of different
ways so I mean we value these these
relationships and I think we certainly
want to continue to work with them I
mean I was on the other side I mean I
sort of was used to working with Google
and you know there's certainly you know
trying to figure out how Google works
and how to navigate the organization
that can be challenging for somebody who
works at Google much less somebody from
the outside and that's a large part of
my job is to try and sort of take that
publisher perspective and one that I
brought in a brought to the table when I
came to the job but also just leave this
in the ongoing discussions that I have
to try and you know make sure that we
can I think sort of tie across all the
different ways that you work with Google
and so to make it a little bit of an
easier interaction it's there's just so
many different things there and on the
product side of it we really try and be
as nimble as possible and have these you
know not have this overarching
bureaucracy that sort of slows us down
but the partnership side of it sometimes
that can present challenges so you know
how do we better engage with publishers
how do we present that more of a
holistic view of you know what can we do
together and just you know leave that
sort of somewhat of white space to say
what and what are the things what are
the important things that we can think
about how can we innovate together how
can we grow this space
you